حزب الديمقراطيه الامريكيه يحكم قبضته
اكثر على مجلس الشيوخ بعد ظهور نتائج
ولايه جورجيا مواطنون جورج الامريكيه
صوتوا امس في انتخابات الاعاده على المقعد
الاخير في انتخابات التجديد النصفي
التنافس كان بين السنتر الحليقه
الديمقراطيه رافايال وارنوك والجمهوري
هيرتشيل ووكر في سباق المحموم فصلت فيه
نقطتان مئويتين ونصف بين المتنافسين فوز
وارنوك منح الديمقراطيين مقعدهم الحادي
والخمسين في مجلس الشيوخ ما يعطيهم مزيدا
من النفوذ في المجلس الذي كان مقسوما بتنا
بالتناصف بين الحزبين لمده عامين النتيجه
توجهت ايضا خيبه الامل على الجانب
الجمهوري الذي توقع موجه حمراء في
الانتخابات النصفيه لكنهم فاشلوا في
السعاده مجلس الشيوخ ونجحه بالحصول على
اغلبيه بمجلس النواب
اسامه
[تصفيق]
برلمانيه كانت امريكا
بالامكان
قالت انها الدروس المستفاده من الانتخابات
المختلفه التي لاحقت هيرشي الصحيفه اضافت
ان ترامب يتحمل جزءا من اللون لاختياره
لوكر في وقت يواجه فيه هو شخصيا ملاحقه
قضائيه متعلقه بالتهرب الضريبيه ترامب
نفسه اصبح اول مرشح جمهوري يخسر الولايات
جورج خلال انتخابات رئاسيه منذ 28 عاما في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الاخيره قبل عامين
النقطه الثانيه هي ان جزءا من الجمهوريين
بداوا الابتعاد عن ترامب خاصه وانا اكثر
200,000 جمهوري صوتوا لحاكم الولايه
الجمهوري الشهر الماضي لم يصوتوا لمرشح
ترامب لمجلس الشيوخ في انتخابات الاعاده
نيورك تايمز قالت ان من بين الدروس
المستفاده ان جورجيا ستكون مره اخرى
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه بعد عامين وان
الديمقراطيين سيحضون بدعم كبير تحديدا في
المدن الكبرى مثل اتلانتا عاصمه الولايه
وان تمثل نحو 60% من القوه الانتخابيه لها
الدرس الرابع حسب ما قالت نيويورك تايم سي
ان مشاعل جمهوريين عبر فرض قانون جديد
مقيد للتصويت لم يجد نفعا فالجمهوريون
شددوا شروط المطلوبه لاقتراع المواطنين في
مصر للاستعاده مقعد مجلس الشيوخ هذا العام
لكنه جهودهم اتت من نتائج عكسيا
شوفي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ننتقل الان الى الانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقبله عام 2024 وجدل على الجانب
الديمقراطي حول ما اذا كان يتعين على
الرئيس جوبيدن الترشح ام لا مجله نيوز ويك
نقلت عن مساعد للرئيس الاسبق باراك اوباما
اقتراحا مفاده انا انصار اوباما يريدون
الى حد كبير رؤيه وجوه جديده على لائحه
الانتخابات الرئاسيه المخاوف بشكل اساسي
تتمحور حول عمر بايدن الذي تجاوز قبل ايام
80 عاما من عمره وانه سيكون في الثانيه
والثمانين حاله انتخابه لولايه ثانيه كانت
استطلاعات رائعه قبل الانتخابات النصفيه
بينت ان غالبيه الديمقراطيين ارادوا مرشحا
اخر غير بايضا لخوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه
بعد عمله
يبدا يعدد متزايد من اعضاء الحزب
الديمقراطيه الامريكيه اعتراضهم لترشيح
الرئيس الحالي جوبايدن في انتخابات
الرئاسه المرتقبه في 2024 لاسيما في ظل
تذمر الامريكيين من اداء الاقتصادي فيما
يقولوا اخرون ان الساكن البيت الابيض
سيكون قد تجاوز 80 من العمر وسط اسئله
تصار حول لياقته الصحيه حتى على مستوى
الحزب نفسه يبدو ان هناك بالفعل اعترافا
بالحاجه الى قياده جديده خاصه بعد النجاح
غير المتوقع لمرشحين في الانتخابات
النصفيه ضد مجموعه من المرشحين الجمهوريين
الضعفاء لذلك اعلنت رئيسه مجلس النواب
نانسي والاغلبيه في مجلس النواب جيمبر
كلاهما يبلغ من العمر 72 عاما مؤخرا انهما
سيتنحيان عن مناصبهما القياديه في
الكونغرس القادم لرفع مستوى مجموعه من
الديمقراطيه من الاصغر وعلى الر من نجاحه
في تجنب موجه حمراء تحت قبه الكونجرس كما
توقع عدد من المحللين والاستراتيجيين في
الانتخابات النصفيه ان اخر استطلاع عن
الراي اظهر رفضه 45% من الامريكيين لاداء
الرئيس
العربيه استطلعت اراء بعض المواطنين
لديمقراطيين وسالناهم هل تؤيدون الترشح
بيضا في الانتخابات القادمه ام تفضلون
رؤيه وجه جديد متابعه
لايك وادي هيستون
وانا اعتقد انه اكثر اثاره للاعجاب من
رئيسنا السابق
لقد قام بعمل رائع كرئيس فهو يهتم بالبيئه
والموظفين والعمال لطالما فعل ذلك ولكنني
اتمنى لو كان اصغر عمرا قليلا
[موسيقى]
اتخاذ قرار بشان من سيرشحون كبديل
الانتخابات ضد ترامب فساد
فور فور
وانا معجبه بعمله وافضل دائما ان ارى
ديمقراطيين في موقع الرئاسه بدلا من
الجمهوريين